hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es mal zwischendurch ein
ganz schnelles rezept und zwar ein
schoko milch shake und ich finde sich
was ganz erfrischend es gerade jetzt an
den heißen tagen muss man nicht extra
weg fahren und sich einkaufen denn das
kann man auch ganz einfach zu hause
selber machen und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal mein lieblingsrezept was
eben richtig schön cremig hier ist vor
allem erfrischend und kalt und zeigt
euch hier einmal kurz die wenigen
zutaten also ich hab hier schokoladeneis
und zwei besetzungen konditor eis da
brauche ich 900 gramm 18 monats kam aber
ich habe hier noch stehen dann brauche
ich einen halben liter milch also 500
milliliter das ist ganz schön kalt schon
aus dem kühlschrank
ich brauche etwas vanille extrakt hier
habe ich 60 gramm shopstar twitter und
später für die dekoration brauche ich
noch sagte dass schokolade oder normale
dunkle schokolade und etwas sahne die
steht allerdings im kühlschrank
denn es ist sehr warm und ich machte
sind heute in blender und vergibt er da
dieser milch shake funktion und das
mache ich jetzt einfach schnell damit
zuerst nehme ich jetzt die milch ich
habe sie jetzt auch nicht vorher
abgewogen denn ich habe hier ein
messbecher dran
das wäre dann doppelt gemoppelt jetzt
500 milliliter spart man sich auch
besorgt ihr dann das eis und starr vor
nehme ich jetzt 700 gramm
und es ist so ein leckeres konditorei
eis ohne emulgatoren das hängt natürlich
dann auch nicht so lange wie so normales
supermarkt eis aber dafür ist es hat
immer schön frisch
dann gebe ich auch direkt die
schokostückchen mit rein
die sorgen eben noch mal dafür dass wir
richtig viel schokolade drin haben
richtig schokoladigen geschmack und
etwas von den extrakt gibt auch ein
bisschen leckeres aroma und das war es
jetzt eigentlich schon
es gebe ich das ganze in und schallt es
hier auf die milchshake stufe und lass
einfach das programm durchlaufen
wenn jetzt nicht diesen kitchenaid
magnetic drive blender habt dann neben
der einfachen normalen mixer oder
normalen blender und muss dann eben
manuell einstellen
wie lange er das eben rühren müsst damit
es eben schön schaumig und cremig wird
also das programm spielt sich hier von
ganz alleine ab jetzt ständig fertig und
das programm sorgt dafür dass es nicht
so warm wird also durch diese reibung
halt immer mal wieder kurz auf damit
wieder schneller
es wird nie ganz schnell zum feiern war
milchshake ich habe zehn kühlpads unter
meinen gläsern und unter der saane sie
habe ich bereits steif geschlagen
jetzt kann ich das ganze verlieren gebe
ich dann noch einen klecks sahne drauf
ich kann man natürlich auch weglaufen
fitness sachen spielst und dann noch
investieren geriebener schokolade und
fertig ist der selbst gemachte
milchshake schoko milch shake in nur
wenigen sekunden den probiere ich jetzt
ich finde gerade diese minimalen
schokostückchen darin echt gut wenig
willkommen mixa noch ein bisschen weiter
laufen lassen
aber ich finde sie super weil ich mag so
schokoladig mit dem kleinen stückchen
und wenn ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht einfach auf meinem blog of
sale ist ob bailly da stehen noch mal
die zutaten waren zwar nur wenige aber
dennoch schreibe ich solch auf und wir
nicht gerne weitere so kleine milchshake
rezept sehen wollt oder andere kleine
rezepte schreibt mir einfach in die
kommentare
und wir sehen uns dann einfach das
nächste mal